مهمة هواة في نيويورك وهناك
أخبار عاجلة لإحضارك من دبي
حيث توجد تقارير عن حدوث
انفجار. ليس من الواضح سبب حدوث ذلك هنا ، ترى
بعض انفجار الفيديو متبوعًا
بحريق ونعلم أنه من
منطقة الميناء الخالية من زقاق الجربيل في
كارولين فاراج المدينة كارولين
فاراج من هو
نائب رئيس الخدمات العربية
معنا
ومحررتنا كارولين أه تنضم إلينا على الخط ما
أنت ما حصلت عليه لنا
جيدًا أه من المكان الذي
أعيش فيه الآن
أنا أمام المنفذ ورأيت
أه منذ حوالي 25 دقيقة أه السماء
أه كان هناك لهب في السماء والمنطقة كلها
تقريبًا أه أصبحت صفراء لذا
أه ثم تبعها مباشرة
بعد ضجيج لذلك قمنا ببعض الهاتف
مكالمات ومسؤولين أكدوا
أنه كان
انفجار حاوية على
إحدى السفن بالميناء
والآن فقط أكد الدفاع المدني
أه أن هناك حريق
اندلع وحاوية داخل ش  IP الراسية
في ميناء جبل علي
حتى الآن هذا هو ما لدينا ولكنهم
لا يمنحون أي
وصول لأي شخص للذهاب إلى الميناء حتى
الآن أو لإعطاء المزيد من التفاصيل
فقط لتأكيد ذلك بشكل صحيح لذلك
يُعتقد أنه حاوية على
الشحن
في الميناء ولكن من الواضح أننا لا نعرف
أكثر من ذلك أخبرنا عن
ميناء جمال علي
بحجمه جيدًا.
أكبر
الموانئ في المنطقة
بأكملها وأيضًا النشاط ليس حرفيًا
بدون توقف
لمدة 24 ساعة وهو أه
معروف بالخدمات وكذلك السعة لذا
فهو منفذ نشط جدًا كما
تعلمون جيدًا وكنا نسمع عن أسئلة
الأعمال وأنا
ومن المفارقات أنه كان لدينا رئيس
رئيس الميناء الذي تحدث عن
أهميته لدبي والطريقة
التي
يعتبر بها ميناء جبل علي أمرًا حاسمًا ،
فأنا أسمع من الآخرين في دبي
كارولين
أنه ليس فقط أه كانت هذه كرة النار
ولكن
هذا أيضًا  هزت الازدهار عبر ci
يمكن الشعور به في جميع أنحاء المدينة
بالفعل بالفعل ، إن أعضاء فريقنا وموظفينا
في CNN موجودون في أجزاء مختلفة من دبي
وقد أكدوا جميعًا أنهم سمعوا
ذلك وبعضهم أقرب إلى الميناء
الذي أكون فيه أيضًا
يمكن أن نشعر به أيضًا ، لكن ذلك
جاء حرفيًا بعد
أن لاحظنا تحول السماء إلى
اللون الأصفر وهذا هو المكان الذي رأينا فيه الإطار